the jurgen experience i had this other
experience
i just wanted to share about um this was
a dmt experience
where i realized that you know we all
have the capacity
for evil if we aren't careful in a sense
so the dmt kind of dissolved my ego very
quickly it was the first time i ever did
dmt it was
sitting in a circle with a group of
people at eslin this was terence mckenna
and
um you did dmt with terence mckenna yeah
yeah
and ralph metzner from firewood and we
would um
there was about eight of us and we would
each of us it takes about 15 minutes 10
15 minutes so we
one person would do it would then sort
of close their eyes lie down and come
back
after 15 minutes or so and then tell the
story about what happened and then we
passed the pipe to the next person and
this was like a whole evening of
dmt stories so my dmt experience was
this
i saw this horizontal line then i saw a
vertical line
then i saw color it turned red then it
turned into cubes
like squares and then it turned into
like an mcesher painting that was just
and then i was gone and it was just it
didn't make sense then i was gone and
then
i just had this insight that in the
deepest recesses of who i think
i am in this inner voice that's kind of
always talking to you this
that i was using english and i didn't
invent english
it's all the product of all these people
that came before me so even in my most
inner private self i'm intermixed with
everybody else and everything that came
before me
and i had this beautiful experience of
going back to the big bang and all of
this kind of
sweep of evolutionary history and i'm
part of everything and everything's part
of me and it was all this beautiful
stuff and then i realized
this sort of logical part of my mind was
like well if everything's part of you
and you're part of everything then
hitler is part of you too
it's inner and and that was very
shattering for me because that was in
the dmt experience it was in the dmt did
you see hitler in the experience
i did and like a million golden hitler's
floating around you
well that that that we all have that
capacity that that if we want to claim
that we're connected with everything
that it's it's not just the evil out
there
that it's potentially in in me and it
was very shattering
and the next day um we did ketamine
and so this is where i did more see
hitler so
this is actually an experience that has
helped me with my political strategy in
a way of what maps is doing
it's both drug development and drug
policy reform
so under this experience the next it was
very
depressing and shattering to realize
that i couldn't just say all the evils
out there that i have this capacity
the hitler's inside me so the next day
under ketamine
i was hovering above and behind hitler
as he's giving one of these
speeches like the nuremberg rally kind
of things
and the ketamine gave me a bit of remove
so i didn't freak out
i was i was there but i was not there so
i didn't feel
vulnerable in that way and i saw him
doing this speech and i'm thinking how
do i get into
his head how do i help him not want to
murder and kill and
you know what can we do to you know undo
this evil
and then i saw this um the heil hitler
salute near the end of his speech and he
would go
you know put up his hand like that and
then everybody in the crowd
would do it back to him and i felt like
it was the one
pushing out this energy and then the
many pushing it back to him
and giving him and they would go back
and forth and the intensity was kind of
increasing and at that
point i was just realizing there's no
way to get into his head
that he's it has to be voluntary and
that he was getting so much
from it that he wouldn't uh
and i felt this panic rising above me
and i felt that if i
were to panic i would never be able to
be effective in the world that i would
just
turn away from that and then with
ketamine you can still breathe
and so i realized that if i just breathe
that might help me deal with this
fear and i started deep breathing and
then
came this idea that ironically rather
than
trying to change the mind of the one we
need to change the mind of the many
and that they don't get as much out of
it as hitler did that they're giving
away their power to him
and so that's where we need mass mental
health
so you hear a lot of people i had a
chance to talk to steve jobs for an hour
a long time ago and um but he was like
stuck in the 60s in a way he was like
god if we could just give all these
politicians lsd
and i think yeah that might be good but
they might resist it but really we have
to base this new
compassion and spirituality in the
masses in
millions tens of millions of people this
this hitler thing can i
ask you like when i've never done
ketamine so when you're having this
experience
what is what is it like do you realize
that you are in a psychedelic experience
that you're in some sort of a
hallucination
or does it actually feel like you
are there like what is it it felt like i
was there
but i had this sense that i was somehow
either
also not there and removed but you knew
that you were tripping
well at the time do you think i i lost
that for a while and as the panic
kind of built up i had this thought i
can breathe so i did have that sense
that i was on a drug and that
if i were just to modulate my breathing
and
that would help relax me so i had that
thought but i felt like i was really
there and it was way
you know i've seen movies of world war
ii and i've seen movies of hitler giving
speeches but i was never
as emotionally connected to it and in
the moment
as i was during this ketamine experience
so it was kind of a dual
situation where i was there but a part
of me
felt removed and safe
and this thought like okay just breathe
um
but but i never had that insight before
about the height hitler salute and how
this energy exchange between and how the
rallies were very dramatic and that's
where he cemented his power
through these rallies well you know
hitler was on all kinds of
drugs yes yeah there was god
i keep forgetting who told us that story
jamie but there's a story about hitler
convincing mussolini do you remember
i've tried i've tried to look it up and
find it i can't i can't find it
it might not have even had it happened
on a podcast that's the problem because
i have so many conversations and
my memory is just so full it's just
there's no room
i got like folders stuffed all over the
place i don't know where anything is but
the story was that hitler was
in the middle of campaigning and he was
completely exhausted and he was supposed
to meet mussolini and he was going to
not meet mussolini because he was so
exhausted
but then they shot him up with
testosterone and liquid cocaine
and when they did that he was just
bouncing off the walls and he cornered
mussolini
and talked to him for five hours and
convinced him
not to leave the effort not to leave the
war effort
and he sort of one of the
the things that this uh story was
basically pointing to was that
much of hitler's mania and much of this
uh
rabid attack that he
had put on the rest of the western world
was fueled by amphetamines
yes and cocaine and testosterone
and that they just kept injecting him
with all this [ __ ] that gave him
this insane confidence and insane
maniacal aggression
and it completely makes sense if you
think about what he did
and then we also know that the kamikazes
were on amphetamines and many of the
nazi soldiers were on amphetamines
well the blitzkrieg how they would do
that this kind of they were
days and days on amphetamines and then
that promotes aggression as well
and just psychotic delusions yeah and he
had this
delusion of creating this master race
which is
and that's the most cocaine idea of all
time right like this idea like where i'm
going to engineer the greatest human
race ever
and you know and and and to be able to
look at that idea
from this cocaine-fueled or
amphetamine-fueled perspective to the
point where you're
willing to commit genocide in order to
accomplish your goal
yeah drugs were a big factor in the
third reich yeah
very much so um also we know that john
kennedy
was given amphetamines that's miss
doctor feel good right yeah
dr feelgood was a legitimate doctor that
would run around and give people and
what'd you find there buddy the story oh
who where's this from
uh historyhit.com did hitler's drug
problem change the course of history
he got a shot of this stuff called yucca
doll okay
hitler took ukidol for the first time
before the dreaded meeting
his mood changed immediately everyone
was very happy that the fewer was back
in the game
his enthusiasm was such that on the way
to the airport to fly to his meeting
with mussolini he demanded a second shot
the first shot had been administered
subcutaneously but the second was
intravenous
it was even better during the meeting
with mussolini hitler was so energized
that he pretty much just shouted for
three hours
there's several reports from that
meeting including
an american intelligence report to the
embarrassment of everyone in attendance
hitler didn't stop talking throughout
the entire duration of the meeting
mussolini couldn't get a word in
edgeways meaning he wasn't able to voice
his concerns about the war effort
and perhaps raise the prospect of italy
leaving
so italy stayed at the end of the day
hitler told morel
the success of today is totally yours
wow so morale must have been the doctor
yes you could do find out what that [ __ ]
is
okay you could do is similar to heroin
in fact it's stronger than heroin it
also has an effect that heroin doesn't
have
it makes you euphoric but i think they
shot them up with some other stuff too
the word was that
it was i'd read harold red cocaine
and oxycodone so i just hit google and
that's what comes up oh
interesting but i had heard and cocaine
it says there are five milligrams of
cocaine too
where is there that under a d i x
wikipedia there
yeah oh is that what's in there meth and
coke mixed together
oh so that's what euca dill is okay that
makes sense so you could do is five
milligrams of cocaine
and three milligrams of methamphetamine
wow so d d i x
it's a a methamphetamine-based
experimental performance enhancer
developed by nazi germany
wow so that's the stuff
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience